the evening is all complete you guys not
being let off the hook
no because it's time for Party Pieces
[Applause]
we're amazing
[Applause]
okay let's see so it's just what have
you got for us well this isn't really a
thing because they said if you've got
any party please and I said not really
and they said we read that you pick up
things with your toes and I was I I
think I said that in an interview once
because they were like do you have any
tricks now as I I can pick anything up
with my toes and now people run the
minute you say that didn't you and your
flatmates have a picking up things with
your toes Olympics yeah well I think
it's the only Olympics ever to happen
yeah we just basically we just stuck
different things in the floor and pick
them up without toes okay so how heavy
can you go can you pick up a pineapple
could you pick that up
oh [ __ ] sorry why not yeah okay okay
hang on
do you want to do it on the table no you
want to do it out there coz if here no
one can see you uh that'll be like a
tree falling a forest
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're gonna do a socks on it's like
showing off is that yeah hang on Olivia
Colman what are you giving us I'm going
to give you a lion a light oh is this
what I need that okay maybe a second or
a sponge okay okay so you need a pint
glass yes
okay so do you need to explain what
you're going to do first no don't think
so no okay okay this is self-explanatory
it's Olivia Colman Gina lion
[Applause]